your character runs into some pretty
awkward situations yeah with with men's
have you had any recently that are fun
to tell in daytime television fun to
tell on daytime
um I can think of several that you'd
have to bleep a lot of it but um we're
already gonna have to believe a couple
it's me too you're good I went on a date
with this man who off the bat was like I
don't know who you are also I was 20
minutes late my bad
um and he was like so drunk like when I
got there he was slurring and like
swaying and over sharing can't hold his
liquor 20 minutes I know 20 minutes yes
and all it took but he was a short King
and um
foreign
but he kept like he kept insisting he
didn't know me and I was like okay
that's odd
um and then he was like don't talk about
me on your podcast and I was like so you
do know me and he was like No And I was
like then how do you know I have a
podcast he's like my roommates and I was
like so your roommates told you about
like you know who I am no yeah and he
was like just don't talk about me and I
was like I absolutely will
I have to you're being insane great
material and then he like offered to
drive me somewhere and I was like I
don't think I should get in the car with
you and I don't think you should drive
yeah he was out of his mind yeah you
know what though thank you for the sign
right off the bat don't waste another
day on that yeah yeah but I did text him
back when he texted me the next day
because red flags to me
it's called desperation you know oh my
God I literally call myself the red flag
collector
about it um anyway uh here literally
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]